ce prêt président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice à travers
votre témoignage vous rebondissez une
nouvelle fois sur ce sujet majeur le
fait que jamais nos forces de sécurité
routière ne rechigne quand elles sont
sollicitées et vous avez raison
au moment où ce groupe d'individus est
apparu dans la ville de dijon
il n'y avait pas eu d'anticipation en
matière de renseignement et pourtant les
forces de sécurité intérieure qui
n'était pas numériquement en capacité de
faire face qui n'étaient pas préparés
ont répondu présent et elles n'ont cessé
de répondre présent ensuite le préfet a
eu connaissance de cela j'ai changé avec
le maire de dijon
j'ai échangé avec le préfet je lui ai
demandé de piloter personnellement la
situation pour faire en sorte qu' il n'y
ait pas ces échauffourées
je dirais bande contrebande et encore je
ne sais pas si on peut qualifier comme
ça cette horde de sauvages totalement
insupportable vous avez raison madame la
sénatrice
il n'est pas question qu'il y ait un
mètre carré dans notre pays où la
république recule y compris face à ces
violences extrêmes et nous devons faire
en sorte que signé nulle part d'états de
non droit et que l'état soit toujours
présent pour juguler juguler ces dérives
totalement insupportable totalement
inacceptable et le phénomène de violence
qu'a connu dijon pendant quatre jours
même si la nuit dernière les choses
étaient apaisées et malgré cela j'ai
demandé au préfet que près de 200 hommes
femmes de la gendarmerie de la police
reste présente j'ai demandé que la berri
et que le raid reste présent aussi dans
les jours qui viennent et ils
reviendront en tant que de besoin
tout comme j'ai demandé aussi à nos
services de police de veillée sous
l'autorité du ministère de la justice à
ce que l'identification des auteurs de
ces exactions commises dès samedi se
poursuivent et qui est des recherches
individuelles pour qu'ils ne soient pas
laissés libres l'idée qu'il serait
impunis ils ne seront pas impunis
madame la sénatrice vous l'avez dit nos
forces de sécurité intérieure ont
répondu à laurent produit avec
l'engagement elles ont répondu avec le
courage et elle mérite pour cela d'être
salué je sais l'émotion je la partage ce
qui s'est passé est inacceptable
il est insupportable et sachez que où
que ce soit en france nous ferons
reculer ces pratiques de voyous
voyez vous